[Music]  very loved here and he's always going to  be a legend here  [Applause]  tim is is on hallowed ground here in San  Antonio is probably the most revered  player but I'd be hard-pressed to say  that man who is not the most beloved  [Music]  the guy that could start 129 other NBA  teams you start in San Antonio then  selfless enough to put those things to  decide for the greater good of our team  he never heard any controversy or any  complaining mano was doing everything he  could to make this to death  try to be a genuine  what-you-see-is-what-you-get people  respect the way he's conducted himself  and the way he's given back to everyone  there's never been another Manu nor will  there ever be so lucky to have him as a  role model so close to me Gramps gracias  nasty Manu  gracias mornin gracias MA gracias man